let's just take a look at that moment
when fabbi won a game where again he
could have been Mater he was material
down uh through most of it here just
take a look I mean you don't expect
Wesley so to lose this position right I
mean equal material now that the Pawn's
been picked up but the B Pawn is under
Fire and I absolutely agree with you and
it was right about in just a few seconds
and look at the clock as well 3 seconds
for Fabby Wesley has those extra and
Fabby sets up this position right now it
doesn't look like it's going to happen
but that white king feeling a bit unsafe
there got off just a little bit and but
check this out Knight takes B5 and what
A Swindle taking away the H5 Square okay
so H5 check and here it comes this is
overloaded and that would be Checkmate
why pass to Capt to the pawn The Rook is
on pre and it is handshakes